I'm not I'm not sure I'm fully convinced
sending money to Ukraine is a good idea
and I think maybe they don't have a
choice right now that they have to do
that but I think there was a different
way of handling that situation because
all it's doing is
you're unifying Iran Ukraine and Iran
Russia and China
and the closer they get and they unify
against U.S I mean U.S is in trouble if
they do that a lot of people are in
trouble if they do that so and Ukraine
is uh
you know he's he's done a great job
become this heroic figure but at the
same time
not comfortable with all of it you're
saying zelinski I'm not comfortable with
all of it I mean I understand Ben
Stiller thinks he's the you know hero or
whatever but you know I'm just I'm just
not comfortable with it it's like hey
this is not enough you need to send us
more money hey this is not enough I'm
just not comfortable with that makes me
very uncomfortable with the way he's uh
raising money and you know asking people
to send money and then he's doing a
photo shoot for what was the one that he
did a Photoshop are you saying that it's
a sense of entitlement yeah I'm not
comfortable with it because the reality
of it is listen so you know again this
goes back to leadership
if the right strong personality is there
the other guy doesn't bully goes back to
the same exact example I gave 20 minutes
ago when there's that one person in the
family and he dies people get bullied
and taken advantage of in that family
when there's this one guy at the bar
that he just shows up and the place is
quiet no one messes with anybody they
just have a good time and then he leaves
then bullies show up and abuse others
yes
I think nobody in the world is
intimidated by bite nobody is and he's
horrible foreign policies without
showing any strength on the way he
handled Afghanistan just opened it up
and said listen if we're ever going to
go after Ukraine this is the time to do
it uh so anyways we've already talked
about that many times I'm not convinced
the solution I look I'm in the insurance
business what is Insurance business risk
no the insurance business it is risk yes
but the insurance business is about
don't buy the product after you have
cancer
don't buy the product after you had a
heart attack don't buy the product the
best part about insurance is buy it
early and keep it insurance companies
make money because people cancel their
policies if you keep your insurance
policies insurance companies don't make
money so it's more preventative right
yeah I understand what you're saying but
then you had a bully called Mr Putin as
well I I understand and the bully
wouldn't be a bully if America had a
leader that knew how to stood up stand
up and be strong the bully only can
bully because there's not somebody else
that says hey knock it off so Putin is
not in Putin doesn't wake up in the
morning or go into sleep thinking about
Biden he doesn't think about that and
you know how certain people in life they
threaten there's certain people you're
not worried about their threat if if Joe
Biden right now said John say something
I want to whoop your ass what would you
do yeah exactly so you don't understand
like the original weight behind his
words and I I don't think we can handle
anything I went to sleep worrying about
Trump
Putin 100 yeah it was unpredictable 100
he had he's through the Chinese of one
million yeah but so Vladimir Putin may
be a bully but he's a pest he's a pest
he's not a threat Xi Jinping is a threat
and and all we're doing right now is
throwing resources at Ukraine we're
running out of the US Army is running
out of ammunition like we are not going
to be able to defend ourselves should we
have to again
it's not like what and Ukraine isn't
like we're going out to defend Japan or
Taiwan or Hong Kong I mean Ukraine has
always been one of the most corrupt
countries in the world so yes while
Vladimir Putin may be a bully all we're
doing is driving him into the arms of XI
Jin pink and and I think it's worth to
think of Vladimir Putin as a Joseph
Stalin while Joseph Stalin wasn't some
hero in the world we we won World War II
because of because of the Russians and
Oliver Stone pointed this out if we
didn't have the Red Army to stand up
against Germany and how powerful Germany
was we would have never won World War II
we wouldn't never won this out so I I
think it's very
uh it's not very beneficial for us to be
throwing billions of billions of
billions of dollars at Ukraine
especially when all we're doing is
driving Vladimir Putin into genes are so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]